eight seconds
[Applause]
[Music]
booster after chamber pressures
vehicle Tower cleared window picks over
propulsion reports first stage engines
nautical what a cycle in the ground
cameras
are flying at twice the thrust of the
same time heading to space
back up
going through the period of Maximum
aerodynamic pressure
[Applause]
so it's a velocity increases the depth
of the atmosphere is decreasing
lessening stress on the vehicle to call
out next few now
[Applause]
continuing to watch the first stage as
we head downrange
[Applause]
100 seconds into flight
our next major activity
over the first stage
Houston tracking station now acquiring
the vehicle
to a shutdown we will get
something we light up six engines in a
staggered sequence and if all goes well
those six engines will burn for almost
six and a half minutes I'm
up and there's views of the Raptor
engines on the second stage as we
prepare for stage separation now after
safe separation the first stage will
flip and begin a boost back maneuver for
landing in the Gulf
[Music]
foreign
continuing to fly two minutes 40 seconds
let's get ready for main engine cutoff
[Music]
as of right now we are awaiting stage
separation
where Starship should separate from the
super heavy booster
yeah Kate right now it looks like we saw
the start of the flip but obviously
we're seeing from the ground cameras the
entire Starship stack continuing to
rotate we should have had Separation by
now obviously this is uh does not appear
to be a nominal situation yeah it does
appear to be spinning but I do want to
remind everyone that everything after
clearing the tower was icing on the cake
and there as you saw as we promised an
exciting end to the Starship inaugural
integrated test flight
[Applause]
everyone here absolutely pumped to clear
the pad and make it this far into the
test light be first integrated light of
the booster and the Starship vehicle
live view bear of our control center at
Starbase which we refer to as Star
Command
as we said before so you can see Elon
Musk there in the center of your screen
watching that launch of spacex's
company's Starship designed to take
humans back to the moon and Beyond it's
the biggest the most powerful rocket in
history and it got off the ground Tom
Clark successfully everyone very happy
about that didn't go completely
according to plan because it didn't
separate when it should have done that's
correct it got as far as doing this flip
maneuver That was supposed to put the
booster in the right aspect for coming
back down to earth and to send Starship
Starship on its way into orbit it
clearly didn't go well it didn't work it
didn't separate the rocket began to
Tumble it then appears just a few
seconds ago to have disintegrated
entirely whether that was deliberate
whether they triggered it to explode or
whether it just you know something got
the better of it we don't yet know
interesting you hear all those engineers
at SpaceX cheering the moment it blew up
which you would have thought you know
they'd be glum-faced and despondent but
interesting it gives you a little
insight into how these Engineers see
tests like this this is where you learn
this is where you understand what's
going wrong and right with your system
your expectations were then just hit
clearing the launch pad was a success I
was I was about to say the fact it got
as far as it did is a huge step forward
that is possibly well beyond many of
them even dreamed of getting